senior hamas commander killed as israel
strikes gaza palestine's fire
rockets this is a reuters story the war
with the worst violence since 2014
between israel and palestinians
showed no sign of letting up ones that's
continued israeli attacks and hamas
rocketed the rocket fires prompted the
us and the united nations to warn the
conflict mushroom
into full-scale war israeli bomb
uh israel's bombing campaign in gaza has
now killed 53 people including 14
children and injured more than 300
people
according to the gaza-based palestinian
health ministry israel's
shin bed security service said the
brigade commander of gaza city was among
senior members of islamic
islamist islamist militant group hamas
who had been killed
militants in gaza have been have fired
more than a thousand rockets into israel
killing six israeli civilians
injuring more than 200 others the
israeli military said wednesday around
130 rockets hit tel aviv last night
forcing israel's main international
airport ben
gurion to close many of the rockets were
intercepted by israel's iron dome which
by the way what a system they have
with the iron dome air defense system
but several struck
tel aviv setting the bus of blaze and
killing one israeli woman thousands of
israel spent the night in
bomb shelters in gaza which has few bomb
shelters and no air defense systems
several buildings and apartments were
damaged by israeli airstrikes
one of those strikes brought a
multi-story tower block tumbling down
the israeli defense forces said the
building
was stronghold of hamas military
intelligence and weapon
research uh i will go to you first adam
tell us what are your thoughts on this
well obviously it's tragic what's going
on but go a little deeper tell us
yeah of course this is this is a sad
situation but unfortunately it's nothing
new
all right i mean this is the first
flare-up in since what 2014
but um i think we've all seen what's
going on with israel and palestine and
it stemmed from the
war 1948 the six-day war when israel
became a state
and egypt and jordan and palestinians
everyone attacked them and in six days
this little country called israel
defended themselves
and they did it in the war of 67 and
71 and then just the yom kippur war and
somehow this little magical country
israel exists in the sea of
um
muslim you know countries all around
them so first and foremost israel does
have a right to defend himself let me
just
state that number two um this is not a
black and white issue so
me being jewish like obviously people
say oh you're biased and that's
obviously you're gonna you know
support israel but i will say that there
are parts of israel that i don't
necessarily
agree with so for instance the
palestinian
the israeli settlements that they're
trying to
um
essentially take over from these
palestinians
families who have been there forever uh
these settlers are definitely aggressive
and it's hard not to sympathize with
somebody who's been living in the same
house
for decades and now settlers come in and
say well the government says it's my
house now and uh
thank you for being here what the hell
would you do if you lived in that house
for 30 40 50 years
and you're palestinian you think you're
giving your house up without a fight
are you kidding me so that's not a micro
issue from a macro perspective
here's how i kind of look at it um it
you know palace
you know you know they say like don't
bring a knife to a gunfight
well palestinians are bringing rocks to
a literal rocket fight
so you know i used this analogy with
ricky the other day and he was that he's
like what the hell's going on there you
know ricky's a big dude
and it'd be like if dylan because dylan
was there kept coming up to ricky was a
big guy and hitting him
and punching him and kicking him yeah
he's only seven years old
but at some point you're gonna hit back
so
you know palestinians are throwing rocks
you know they're
literally launching rockets uh and
israel is gonna only take it to a
certain extent when they said listen you
do that again and we're gonna
excuse my language kick your ass
and that's essentially that's
essentially what netanyahu said yes
exactly yeah
so at some point if you know and i'm not
comparing palestinians to a
seven-year-old but
in terms of strength they're no
comparison
to what the palestinian or the plo or
hamas has
compared to what israel has but at some
point
look it's such a tough situation that i
do actually sympathize with the
palestinians and i've been to israel i'm
jewish i have family that lives in
israel
i have a cousin of mine who moved from
detroit to join the idf
so yes i have some bias here but i do
understand the plight of the
palestinians
if you're constantly a second-class
citizen
in where you live how do you expect to
react so this goes down to the another
macro perspective the one state or the
two-state solution so john kerry
who was um was john kerry's secretary
secretary of state
okay so he said the jewish people cannot
if you do a one-state solution you're
familiar with the one-state two-stage
solution if you do a one-state solution
because there's more arabs living in
israel than jews
he said if you do a one-state solution
israel can no longer
be jewish and or democratic it cannot be
both
so a two-state solution both have the
right to exist the problem is
and i'll turn it over to bernie after
this the problem is there's
people in hamas who are a terrorist
organization that are running
palestine the palestinian terrorists the
united states has labeled
the people running the palestinian
territory a terrorist organization hamas
they do not believe that israel has a
right to exist just like how in iran
um the the people running the azerbaijan
army there's a bunch of them
they do not believe that israel has the
right to exist so
on a fundamental basis if you do not
believe a country
if you're not exactly azerbaijan doesn't
believe armenia has a right to exist
that's what you're saying
if you saying that you don't believe a
country has a right to exist and you're
doing everything
to usurp their who's to blame who's to
blame here listen i i understand that
you know trevor nor
you know trevor noah i don't know when
you heard what he said you know he was
like well
if when i was younger and i was a older
brother
and i would beat up my younger siblings
my uh mom would say
but my mom they hit me first and one
would say but that's your brother why
are you hitting him all this other so
why are you hitting them
the difference here is this is not your
brother like this is not like this is a
very difference
you know what they're not hitting them
either the
hamas i think you said fired over a
thousand rockets a thousand rockets
if it wasn't for the iron dome they
would have killed
hundreds hundreds of israelis
thousands potentially thousands
potentially
yeah thousands of rockets they they shot
right
the bottom line is we're not talking
about a fist fight we're not talking
about somebody getting hit
we're talking about deadly physical
force right
if you infuse that force if you you go
out
it doesn't matter who you are it doesn't
matter who you are it doesn't matter
what the argument is
you know there's ways to deal with the
argument you know there's a hundred ways
to deal with the argument
and i think the un for once should
probably do a better job
they've never done a good job but they
should be doing more to rectify
the internal issues but the bottom line
is you can't shoot rockets into israel
deadly rockets and they anticipate
they're not going to shoot back
yeah just think about like netanyahu's
press conference well look
to the israeli people i'd like to speak
to you i know we got
bombed and i know we had 100 rockets
that were shot our way
in a span of uh five minutes or ten
minutes whatever the number was
they're smaller army than us we
shouldn't retaliate
god talked about forgiveness you should
forgive them he would not be
like no no what i'm saying to you is
forget it's netanyahu yeah
say biden gives that speech we're
america yes 9 11 happened but we
shouldn't retaliate
no no this country is not say you're
rush
say you're any country if a prime
minister says this what do you say
you're you're the voter you're fired
you're you're right that's what i'm
saying you're a mother with three kids
and the only thing the mother thinks
about with their kids is the s
word what is it security and safety
right
you want me to sit there and say well
netanyahu this is why this israeli
they're they're
they're too aggressive they're too this
they're too that what is the alternative
to look the other way when you're
looking at what is is that going to
cause hamas and palestine to stop
no they're not they're going to continue
doing what they're doing so
my my my challenge with this is
you when you get into topics like this
you'll get people from both sides
you know you're you cannot believe you
said this came this is not about me
taking israel's side or palestine side
if you're gonna do something like this
you best do something like this knowing
you can beat israel you can't
if you're gonna start a fight you better
believe you can finish the fight
what is the point of starting a fight if
you know it's not going to favor you
like what it's emotion like something
that i've had to learn here
being a part of valuetainment and
everything is try to be more logical not
emotional can you imagine the emotion
of somebody they killed my grandson
they took my house is you're running on
pure emotion you think there's logic
in behind their actions they're mad
they're angry they're upset they're
still
they're still angry that someone killed
their cousin from 40 years ago and
they're harboring that anger what do you
expect them to do no
i'm not defending i'm not justifying
their armenian and armenia went up
against
azerbaijan azerbaijan's got five times
the amount of budget you got with
backing of erdogan turkey the largest
military in the middle east
while putin doesn't have the backing of
armenia putin does business with turkey
you think putin is going to take the
side of armenia back him up who's going
to defend palestine and hamas to say hey
you're going to go up against israel
we'll back you up and go defend a war
against israel
the most ridiculous air force in the
world won the best military technology
rejection
most insane you know secret intelligence
you want to go up against somebody like
the idea of
well i don't know to bernie's point and
you bring up an amazing point here the
fact that israel
10 years ago they
they invented this iron dome which
essentially is a missile defense
mechanism that with 90 plus percent
accuracy you can shoot down
rockets that are coming over its border
imagine if they didn't have that
that's what i'm saying imagine if they
didn't have that thousands of missiles
landed in the country yeah
people are protesting israel they're
using the forest they're using force
imagine a thousand people died would
israel have the justification to do what
they want no there's
of course but but here's a complete
different story here
i'm going to go completely different
angle you know what that dome did to me
when i saw it
what did it do to you when you saw that
what like forget about when you saw like
you know how you see it in the videos
like boom you're like
yeah what did you think about when you
saw that you i've seen that for years
but
i get that when you see it what do you
think about it the ridiculous technology
okay
you think about safety you think about
wow that's pretty sick you think about
the direction we're going
where security and safety from doing
wars
is gone meaning if you want to bomb a
place those days the technology is
getting so advanced that countries are
going to be able to put a
bio you know this kind of a dome over or
a person it's not a literal dome
i know of course yeah
think of this you know and i i i have a
lot of friends in the special operations
community right
think of this today in washington dc
somebody somebody could pick up a phone
and call somebody in dc and say
we have a guy this is his grid
coordinates
he could be on the other side of the
universe
some completely like somewhere hidden
somewhere wherever within
30 minutes we the united states
has an ability to drop a bomb on that
guy's head
no matter where he is in the world think
about that
no matter where he is you know why do
you feel hearing that
that the fact that we have these
capabilities yeah i mean it's ridiculous
it makes does it make you feel safe does
it make me feel safe that we could do
something like that
it doesn't make me feel unsafe okay no
but but what i'm saying to you is the
fact that folks in israel
yeah they they ought to be grateful
for the technology advancement that that
country's invested in
to provide that kind of security because
here's how small is israel
israel is not a big country this is the
size of like delaware yeah israel is so
tiny it's ridiculous and by the way
palestine's even smaller like when you
think about how small
it's and it's not it's it's not also
just
wartime capability right when the fbi
had a hard time getting into the iphones
right who'd they go to yeah they go to
the israelis well there's an amazing
book called startup
nation uh that i read i don't know 10
years ago and it talked about how this
little it's like the little engine that
could how this little country
was able to manifest itself into this
ridiculous technologically advanced
country uh and i'll say one thing
because i'm sure we'll move on to the
next topic but
we were texting ironically yesterday or
dm'ing yesterday
on the plane you remember this yeah
and you and we were talking about uh
israel and tel aviv
and you go i guess we're not opening up
a valuetainment office in tel aviv
anytime soon
and i go and i've been to tel aviv i
actually said the opposite yeah you said
i guess we i guess
i guess we are yeah because of how safe
it is okay i thought you were being
sarcastic
say about tel aviv i'm from miami i'm
from i'm from maya beach
it's like miami beach bro like it's like
you go to the beaches you're having a
great time you go to the discotheques
you're dancing you're doing the uh
you're having fun you're living a life
that you would not think you're living
in
in the middle east it's awesome uh yeah
but adam you know what
that's all over the middle east you know
when we're watching you're watching
video of syria right you're watching
the bombs and the you know the the
knocking out
uh sites and doing all this other stuff
you go online you go on facebook and
you'll see people in syria
they're having weddings they're having
parties they're going out to restaurants
and you're looking at this thinking
where the is that guy because
i just saw this morning in aleppo yeah
right
i just saw this morning where they
annihilated an entire city
and this guy's getting married you know
that's all over the middle east
why because it's the way they've learned
to live
they had to live like this you know i
worked i worked for the king of jordan
for five years
and jordan's a pretty secure country
jordan has
been great for the last it's been great
40 years um but i was also there
in november of 2005 when they bombed the
three hotels
right in all over this country everybody
was saying oh my god
it's it's losing it it's not going to be
secure anymore
there's no security in jordan and yet i
was in jordan
i don't know 70 times over five years
um it's phenomenal it was a phenomenal
country
it's the way they've learned to live
it's it's the way the israelis
have learned to live they have to you
know you go into a mall
in tel aviv you're going to be checked
for weapons you're going to be checked
for a vest
that's the way and every every uh
israeli citizens and bless you from the
day they turn 18 has to join the idea of
israeli defense force
and you're learning everyone has guns
have in the guns in the country
everyone has them ak-47s whatever it is
and it's a very safe place you feel very
secure so
as a jew as a jew you know
you go there and it's it's not what you
like for instance the jewish people in
america they they you kind of get this
like uh everyone feels safe
no not at all exactly
you feel like every jew is like a mud
greenberg from the family guy and he i'm
at the pharmacy like that's what's uh
but they're they're freaking badasses
it's ridiculous
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
you